[Musique]
raconter incontournable sergio grondin
aime les mots et c'est les partager pour
raconter les vies les gens de son pays
la réunion ce mardi et de saint joseph
nous accueille dans son petit paradis
nous allons retrouver ici à lille est
m
[Musique]
merci serge grondin accueil à nanterre
là au coeur du festival la belle parole
à saint joseph saint joseph co2 ville où
ça où l'aîné ou ça le talent l'aîné
aussi le coz est là outre l'amour pour
les mots cei vient sans écoute dont
l'amour pour les mots il vient
d'abord de remparts en 30 matches où tu
ailles paca moutons puisque mon papa te
sortent pas comme un automate uta et
puis me pense il vient directement de
moments parce que moment ça madame y
chante ça madame y cause ça madame miyem
la parole donc le causés sont là ils
sont d'abord deux repas aborderont par
où il a besoin de raconter et que ça on
y aime raconter en fait même bien me
raconte bonne demande nomme les hommages
à la main sinon ça n'a de la main si un
verre d'alcool enfin parce que na poin
rien que ça qui travaillent là aussi ça
qui subit et nous nous sommes dit qu aux
longs cheveux blonds yabeun mahul bonne
pas john tous à la méme raconte bonne
monde la main ça c'est ça c'est mon
mouna - ça c'est justement le festival à
la belle parole coup la montée c'est
pour mettre en avant l'art oratoire
quelle est la place de l'art oratoire
aujourd'hui à la réunion donc là on va
toi aujourd'hui les patous lille et
donne dans la bouche vous raconter des
histoires de mode comme eric laurès mais
aussi dans la bouche bank and have i
done la bouche bonne jeune maman qui
fait là commence enfin l'art oratoire
lille et lille est partout et lille et
lille et vivant lit comme la langue des
contenus des vivants ils demandent qu'à
pouvoir sortir encore plus comme le 8
juin 1966 le mal
ok hadas internationalement connu dans
son quartier du sud de la réunion
les plus grands ont joué au poker à
enrico macias sheila les frères jacques
oui après on a les plus grands qu'on
méritait bien de faire le festival ici
là dans l'île est ce un choix sa pensée
n'est pas anodin non non parce que parce
que cet endroit là c'est l'ancien
monocoque ou s'annulent évincé l'ancien
monocoque donc c'est un affaire ils
portent l'histoire la commune i pans de
l'histoire d'un peu toute la réunion au
site où trônent cox est l'endroit où il
co écrit où ils paris c'est des endroits
de communication qu on la trouve ce lieu
là bas
trouve notre place bout du compte quand
tu vois nous laisse où la falaise de
l'endroit il doit fait à 145 poisson
d'humidité dans l'air mais nous les
aussi dans l'endroit était vivant et
qu'il est encore vivant et l'important
site connaître ça nous vient nos
traditions c'est pour çà ou là ce
spectacle a notamment maloya comme ça
jouer dimanche
ce spectacle là c'est pour mettre par
les doutes propre cas barco said dabach
à mon cabas c'est la langue
comment la dû construire parce que quand
miley n'est la première fois ce mondial
it en français et ce à la bousculade -
sa réunion que li na na sera pas ça de
la mienne mais sera quand même la
réunion et sa langue sera pas seulement
la langue créole sera sa langue
ali un jour daniel m'a dit on va voir si
le jeu sera pas si dans tellement aisé
que ce qu'avaient les coûts de
marmailles
alors tu vas voir sergio ça va pas être
si simple de lui parler en créole à ton
gamin j'ai demandé pourquoi il m'a
expliqué très simplement et bien que les
jaunes sa génération il est un peu plus
de 60 ans avait vécu comme comme
préserver du monde extérieur mais que
nous eh bien on était né avec ce fameux
monde idéaux et que dans ce monde là et
bien c'est simple la langue maternelle
elle n'existe pas sergio grondin sur
scène c'est une présence et une
puissance d'interprétation parce que
seul en scène et pouvoir dégager autant
d'énergie me trouve ça impressionnant
passe par les pattes sous sol c'est
parce que nous on a conscience que la
parole il passe à travers nous mais les
panneaux qui borde la parole là bas
c'est juste un passé a donc on n'est pas
tout seul sur le plateau
qu'est ce qui est important de
transmettre pour sergio grondin l'amour
sel c'est la femip ans le premier le
premier à faire c'est l'amorcé chemin de
vie la dyade munguia maso dire deux mots
ni photo thiam azote et comme dit alain
peters fonnier a mano c'est le premier
le seul à fait amis pensent même à nous
alors